Oh
as explorer-in-residence at the National
Geographic I have license to play I have
a relatively long leash to be able to do
what the title suggests go explore it's
it's really great to have the backing of
that institution it gave me a little
nest in Washington DC and the support to
go out and put together expeditions to
find the resources to do what I try to
do best that is to explore research
understand and take care of the the
ocean especially the wild natural parts
of the sea
people have been exploring from the
surface for as long as people have been
getting to the ocean but getting into
the ocean it's still tricky business and
it's only in very recent times that
we've had the technology that can take
us more than as deep as you can go
holding your breath perhaps some people
did that centuries ago but to actually
go down and stay a while to be able to
go to a thousand feet 10,000 feet
ultimately the full ocean depth that
takes more than we carry around with us
in our skin you need to have technology
as a partner why because that's where
the action is that's where most of life
on earth is that's where most of the
water is 97% of Earth's water is ocean
without without the ocean without water
earth would be much like Mars a bleak
barren inhospitable place for the likes
of us and the rest of life on Earth as
well I somehow understood this from an
early stage men imagining first of all
what is the ocean what is the ocean and
then what would it be like without the
ocean one thing that we didn't know when
I first began exploring was how
extensive the mountains and valleys or
even life itself is in the sea the
discovery of mountain ranges of plate
tectonics the processes that that drive
the movement of continents that shape
the character of oceans oceans come and
go over long periods of time those
things have only come into focus during
the 20th century mostly during the
latter part of the 20th century and so
far we've only seen about a five percent
of the ocean it's a huge part of the
solar system this planet that has not
been looked at even once let alone put
on the balance sheet with with respect
to understanding how the world works and
why we need to take care of the ocean